Hey, welcome back. It's day 20. This is officially the halfway point.
Today we're in Romans chapter 12 and verse number
one. All right. "Therefore, I urge you, brothers and sisters, in view of
God's mercy, to offer your bodies as a living sacrifice,
holy and pleasing to God. This is your true and
proper worship."
Now, if you're taking notes, I want to give you the answers to several questions
about this verse. Number one, who should make the sacrifice?
I want you to notice that it said brothers and sisters.
Now, this is not physically brothers and sisters, not Jews, but brothers and
sisters in Christ. So he's talking to Christians, not unbelievers.
So this is not about getting saved.
This is post-salvation. All right, question number two, how do I
make this sacrifice he's talking about?
I want you to notice the word present or offer.
This is the same word that we ran into in Romans six yesterday.
So when it says in Romans six, "Yield your bodies as servants of righteousness,"
it's using the same word as this one, present.
Now, I think this is important because it answers an
interesting question that we need to deal with.
How long does it take to make this sacrifice?
An old preacher, B.J. Walker, just passed away recently.
I heard him preach when I was younger, and he said, "The holiness that God has for
you after the new birth is approached gradually,
entered into suddenly, and walked in indefinitely."
Now, that's true. Everyone
Paul was writing to would be familiar with this process.
It might be a while gathering the sacrifice.
It might be a while making the journey to the temple, getting there,
waiting your turn,
prepping the sacrifice. But everyone knew there was a moment where the
sacrifice was presented, and I take my hands
off, and after that,
it was over. Right? Now, maybe you've struggled for a long time
with control of your life.
There's a time where you just be like, "We're not going to struggle anymore.
We're going to simply yield and put up a huge yes sign in my heart." Now,
question number three, what should I yield or sacrifice?
What is it that he's asking? Well, notice it says your bodies.
Now, why is it your bodies? Well, here's why.
Because when God gets your body, He gets it all.
If He gets your hands, He gets what you touch, what you click, what you pick up,
what you drop. If He gets your mouth, He gets what goes into it and what comes out
of it. If He gets your feet, He gets where you go, when you stop,
when you push the gas and the brake. Right?
If He gets your eyes, He gets what you look at and how you see
people. You get the idea.
Now, some people have said, "Well, wait a minute.
Didn't I do that when I got saved?"
Well, in a way, yes. You gave
up sin and rebellion, but now you may face
choices like reading the Bible with your eyes versus closing them
in sleep. Right? And in those moments, we often make decisions based
on our emotions, what we feel like.
But God's calling you to give Him control over bad and good.
Sleeping, eating, sexual life, reading material, musical choices, those are all
things that are not sinful in and of themselves.
So this isn't talking about just giving up actions of sin.
It's deeper than that. It's talking about giving up
control of blessings.
Now, to make right decisions, to know God's perfect
will, you're going to need to make this sacrifice and
yield your body. Question number four,
when should I present this sacrifice?
I want you to notice that it says it's a living
sacrifice. You remember wanted posters in the Old West, right?
"Wanted, dead or alive." Yeah, well
God only wants you alive. This means
that this sacrifice isn't something that happens at the moment of death.
All right? I'm going to live my life for myself, living the self life as a
Christian, halfway in, halfway out.
But then I'm going to get this taken care of just at the moment when I'm on
my deathbed, and that's when I'm really going to make the sacrifice. No.
He's not talking about that. He wants you now.
He wants you presented alive, living completely holy for
Him right now. Question number five, what
qualifications do I need to make this sacrifice?
Now, I want you to notice it says holy and acceptable, holy and
pleasing to God. Before you're saved, you're not alive, and
you're not holy, and you're not acceptable.
You are dead in trespasses and sins. Remember Ephesians 2? You're lost.
Even your righteous acts are like filthy rags.
God would never say to a sinner, "Present your body holy and acceptable,"
because they're not.
But He would to Christians.
He would to you. Question number six, how, or why, I'm
sorry, should I make this sacrifice?
"I urge you, brothers and sisters, in view of God's
mercy"
because He's been so good to save you, because of your influence, because of the
shortness of your life, because of the fruitfulness your life needs to have,
because of the uncertainty of the future, and because God is gracious to
you in salvation. Now, when?
When should I make the sacrifice? The answer is
right now.
Years ago, when I was a sophomore in high school, Reverend Mark Sankey
was a preacher that came to preach a revival to
us, to those high school students that I was a part of in the Christian high
school. So he preached every day a sermon in our morning
chapel. And in that one sermon, he preached
from this verse. This verse is special to me in this area.
He preached
a message called "God Wants Your Everything."
And he preached, and he went through the alphabet, actually, and he said, "God
wants your apples and
then your Bs." He went through all of them, then said a bunch of B things, and then
your C things, all the way through.
I think when he got to X, he did Xerox machines and xylophones.
I
just know that
in that sermon, I came face to face with the fact that
though I had been a Christian for years and had been following the Lord since
I was very small,
I realized that there were blessings in my life I had never
surrendered fully to God, the blessings of a body saved
and holy and right before God,
that I had never yielded those blessings, my strength, my ability,
my mind, my thinking, my intellect, which were not
unholy. They were holy, and I should offer them holy
to God.
And I remember standing in the back of that
chapel service that morning,
and I remember thinking,
"That is good. I should do that someday.
Sometime I should do that."
And as clearly as
I'm sitting here, the Lord said to me,
"Why not now?
Isn't this the day that you should do that?"
And I did, and it made a tremendous difference in my life.
It didn't mean I never had anything else I had to surrender.
It didn't mean that I didn't have to update it sometimes.
It just meant that I had made a decision
that the blessings and the holy things of my life, my body,
completely was surrendered to God,
and I would encourage you to do the same thing. I'll see you tomorrow.